there's no bigger flex in having a
scoped weapon and then choosing not to
use it expecting taz to push an oh
fluffs his lines he's giving a second
chance what screw the scope he rips it
off the orp but whether you're looking
for style points or just got caught
unprepared with a sniper rifle in your
hands no scopes always bring the hype
but before we start i just gotta remind
you all to hit the like button the
subscribe button and to ring the
notification bell because we're super
close to 2 million subscribers ah but
after you do that sit down buckle up and
get ready because today we are counting
down the top 10 noscopes and esports
kicking off our list is an incredible
sequence that makes the marshall look
busted courtesy of vivokeed's heat let's
see if there's anything left in the tank
what can they bring us here already
heat's going to spot out most of the
plane also just takes off oh my keeper's
head the follow-up as well
this ain't pretty
back at masters berlin he'd absolutely
destroyed zeta division sure it was
against an eco but this was an ace with
four unscoped kills gross
i could watch this all day like this i'm
like okay that's fine
fair enough though stacked up
that's quite nice out isn't it it's
quite nice
coming in at number nine is a filthy
scout nose goat from pes he might find
another and he does anger down and now
the a bomb site oh sean just missing
that flick
and pit
gonna find a double there nice jump
scout onto sean that's gotta be an
insult to injury but it's all down to
double walk in a one versus three back
at esl pro league season two pith pulled
out the budget boom stick for a clean
double kill against cloud9 that was a
no-scope scout too
both of them were no scope scouts the
decision to not even try to scope that
second one on sean gears and just let it
fly
that takes confidence
now this list might be competition only
but we've got ninja at number eight well
a play from ninjas days as a pro halo 5
player it's tied up it's 44 to 44.
in halo the sniper rifle is notorious
for having a lenient hip fire but it's
not typically the weapon you count on in
close quarters when everything's on the
line roy is way too out of position here
oh my god why is he shooting that guy
he's gonna shoot him anyway kratos gets
killed by and then suspecter gets the
kill under roy it's tied up it's 44 to
44
he hits it where's the last kill one
second
ninja goes huge oh my god what is
happening right now ninja had a
reputation for making some risky plays
but keeping the sniper for yourself and
no scoping with seconds left on the
clock when your team needs a kill is
something else
in 2015 the summer of cloud nine was in
full swing and shroudy rowdy was turning
heads if not for his biceps than for
plays like this one still fanatic in
control of this round fighting a lot
more than they really need to they just
wait until they get close to the side
here and shroud gets a kill grim's gonna
go down shroud showing up
back at the very first esl pro league
finals shroud closed out round two of
the first map with a bang after getting
three scoped kills shroud decided just
to try one without and even his
teammates couldn't believe it
one more time
there is a certain amount of risk in any
no-scope attempt but sometimes it's a
long shot that still hits home like this
incredible overtime wallbang from fallen
at number six they're gonna be able to
get the bomb plant and happy even
waiting for the push in fallen gets the
spray shot anyway
what
what is that back at esl one cologne
2015 fallen just pointed his gun through
some smoke and left-clicked even though
his team lost the round it was an
unbelievable shot but did he really just
no scope wall bang apex through smoke
apex is even like what the hell was that
oh my god sometimes you get those frags
those moments in cs or just your brain
kind of goes on tilt it just pauses
because what the hell just happened yeah
i think that might have been one of
those moments for him oh wow that was
godlike we've all whiffed a cheeky no
scope through smoke when the opponent
already knows we're there but when
fallen tries it he gets results
at number 5 is a halo 5 play that gives
us the chills courtesy of frosty at the
2016 hcs pro league na summer finals
making a charge picks it up immediately
and rips off hook's face no scoping
someone when you have time to prep is
one thing but what about when you've
just picked up the weapon and have to
hit a shot while moving let's find out
who's gonna be walking away as the
summer season champions kicking things
off with frosty's pov frosty headed
straight for the sniper making a charge
picks it up immediately and rips off
hook's face who wanted that sniper but
frosty's got other plants no scoping
someone like this at the beginning of a
map in the air this is just a display of
pure dominance
coming in at number four is kenny s
absolutely embarrassing nip during
faceit league 2015.
comes kenny s
oh my god kenny s with three insane
kills caught in a 1v3 in ct spawn kenny
only needed the scope for the first kill
after that it was child's play for the
op maestro even at close range hitting a
jumping target isn't easy and he
actually had time to go defuse and win
the round turning around good chunk of
damage done
let's finish dropping comes kenny s oh
my god kenny s with three insane kills
and he has time wait are you telling me
he's gonna win the round has he got time
yeah he's got time unbelievable no i
can't believe this man no
at our number three spot it's yampy
proving that whatever game he plays he
can always make some magic happen what
is that a ridiculous retake he didn't
even need his teammate in the end he
didn't even need a scope tom
back at vct stage two challengers yempi
reid took havens b site with two smooth
no-scope op shots b is definitely not
the place you want to be when it comes
to these after plant scenarios it can be
topped off
it's one of the last weapons you'd want
in hand when trying to enter a site
alone but yampi must have some toggle
that makes a thing fire shotgun shells
instead incredible stuff
you knew this one had to make an
appearance taking number two on our list
is simple's falling double no scope that
shocked the counter-strike world you see
it double smoke's in the same place
there simple just jumping casually into
the side he's gonna fall
are you serious what is that you can't
do that simple that's not allowed this
is not fpl this is a major at esl one
clone simple made cs go history dropping
down from heaven while getting too
unbelievable
no-scope kills onto fnatic it's
immortalized it's unforgettable and it
just never gets old just listen to the
crowd's reaction to the replay
simple i i don't know man if he comes in
with that there's nothing he's done
there was no zoom
you know it we know it there's only one
no scope that could possibly be number
one coldzera's jumping up here he comes
once again the first base is a trend
he's going to hit the ground there it's
cold
that's jumping double from cold what is
it going on right now how does he do
this
corner safely velocity with your play
unthinkable scenes there on the b
apartments at the columbus major
coldzera hit the single most insane shot
cs go has ever seen and then he did it
again and again and again three
no-scopes four kills two while jumping
and one of them was a collat was there
some luck involved obviously yes is this
the kind of play you want to encourage
your teammates to try no ridiculous
stuff
that's the most ridiculous thing i've
ever seen but did it work here and rub
serious salt into a huge wound
absolutely here he comes once again the
first base is the trend he's going to
hit the ground there is cold oh
wow that's jumping double cold what is
it going on right now how does he do
this there's a reason you've seen it a
million times it's a once in a lifetime
play and it's still cool as hell
that is the list a couple of old
favorites and a couple we featured from
games we don't normally cover all in all
a top tier list that was actually really
hard to pick for if you think we missed
one let us know down the comment section
below take care and i'll see you in the
next one
sentinel someone out of position they
know what's happening right now and
we'll get players coming through tense
straight into what can you dodge oh my
god tens you know what the best player
in the world says i don't need it i'm
just gonna notice him
since whilst he's inside the cloud just
insane actually insane frag from tents
oh he was tracking the muzzle flash